me dire que j'allais tomber enceinte on
se dit tout le temps ça peut arriver
qu'aux autres pas vous ce qui me
dérangeait c'était de l'annoncer à la
famille comment j'allais le faire vous
avez été très nombreux à être ému voir
bouleversé par le témoignage de cette
toute jeune maman célibataire de 14 ans
Linda et a demandé de ses nouvelles
qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir quoi toutes
les deux tout ce qui m'attache à la
société pour l'instant c'est ma fille
quoi en 1994 elle me racontait ses
fugues son mal-être comment ce bébé
était venu combler à affectif dû en
grande partie à l'absence de son père
qu'elle recherchait aujourd'hui j'ai
retrouvé Linda elle a 44 ans elle est
fonctionnaire
territorial
Linda tellement plaisir ça m'a fait
aussi ça me fait aussi beaucoup de bien
de vous revoir c'est vrai oui en te
revoyant ça ouais je préfère hein je
préfère ça sera plus simple reevyant ça
m'a permis quand même de de réaliser
tout le chemin parcouru hein parce que
aujourd'hui je suis maman de deux
enfants Mathis a presque 18 et ma fille
en a 30 aujourd'hui en fait tu t'en es
bien sorti j'ai ouais tu dirais ça ou
pas ah oui je m'en suis bien bien sorti
j'ai j'ai eu beaucoup de chance j'ai pas
j'ai pas à me plaindre j'ai une vie
professionnelle
épanouie mais alors comment tu t'es
débrouillé parce que tu avais 14 ans tu
tu arrêtais l'école tu reprenais l'école
tu avais ce bébé comment tu tu l'as fait
pour pour avoir un métier comment tu
t'en es s suis parti de l'abri 18 ans
l'abri il faut dire que c'est c'est le
foyer de maman célibataire he qui m'a
accueilli qui a été ma deuxème maison
mon refuge et donc je me suis mise à
faire des stages des formations par-ci
par là ça a été compliqué vraiment ça a
été compliqué aujourd'hui je peux le
dire hein je sais à quel point ça peut
être difficile j'ai vécu des moments
terribles tu imagines et financièrement
aussi terrible ça a été le cas
cataclysme germinal il y a eu des
moments où je l'ai vécu chez moi pendant
cette période j'ai vécu des choses assez
compliquées hein tu as le surendettement
tu as les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne à assumer et tant que tu
n'as pas cette stabilité là tu es tu as
peur du lendemain c'est ça qui a été le
plus dur ça a été ouais par rapport au
manque affectif c'est plus effectivement
le travail ouais ça a étit ça ouais
parce que justement tu as pas le temps
tu as pas le temps la vie te laisse pas
le temps d'avoir tes douleurs internes
tu as l'urgence vitale en
priorité mais pas pour moi pour elle
pour elle est-ce que tu as souffert des
préjugés j'ai été souvent jugée par le
fait de la fille facile qui a eu un
enfant à 14 ans quand tu te présentes un
emploi sur ton CV il y a quand même
l'enfant quoi donc
et des fois ça peut laisser induire des
choses dans l'esprit de la personne en
face qui sont pas très très respectueuse
même hein mais ouais le regard de
l'autre ouais c'est pas simple non maman
célibataire à 14 ans surtout dans les
années 90 un cas
social qui ne l'est pas
finalement si ma fille je l'aurais pas
eu si elle n'aurait pas été là je pense
que j'y serai encore dehors parce que
tout ce qui m' tout ce qui m'attache à
la société pour l'instant c'est ma fille
quoi et est-ce qu'avec le recul tu
dirais que ta fille t'a sauvé des
errances de la fugue ce que tu disais à
l'époque elle m'a sauvé elle m'a permis
de de partir peut-être tôt mais au juste
moment hein euh vers une autonomie vers
une indépendance elle m'a pris la
résilience la persévérance
elle m'a permis d'être moi en fait elle
m'a permis d'être
moi tu disais nous allons grandir
ensemble je grandirai en même temps
qu'elle en fait et à partir de là je
verrai c'est vrai parce qu'en fait c'est
ben c'est ce qui s'est passé on a vécu
des tas de choses he ça a pas été
évidentin je crois que là-dessus il faut
être très très clair c'est c'est pas
facile d'être parent de nos jours et
celleel encore moins quand tu as 14 ans
tu vis par tu pass se tout seule tu
passes par des moments très compliqués
tu as toujours la peur au ventre quand
même qu'on te l'enlève de pas être
capable ça c'est des choses qui restent
c'est des choses qui reste tu as eu peur
comme ça j'ai j'ai eu peur mais très
très longtemps hein et même avec le
deuxième hein je pense qu'il y a des
séquelles qui restent et qui sont
installés en toi dans ton fonctionnement
et
euh et tu fais ce que tu peux comme tu
peux tu essayes toujours d'être au
maximum et vous pensez que vous serez
vigilante en fait je tiens à établir
entre moi et ma fille une relation de
mère et fille mais tout à et tout à la
fois une relation quand même à qui elle
peut parler parce que ma mère é était
pas vraiment ouverte avec moi je pouvais
pas lui parler de la
sexualité j'avais beaucoup de mal et on
a pu en fait établir une relation où il
n'y a aucun tabout entre moi et ma fille
je peux le dire je peux l'affirmer
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun tabout
tu as fait le contraire de ta mère oui
c'était primordial c'était primordial et
alors est-ce que ta fille est à la
recherche comme toi tu l'as été ton
propre père est-ce qu'elle a été à la
recherche de son père oui mais elle a le
dire en fait dès qu'elle l'a dit à
l'époque je travaillais au commissariat
central de Montpellier et j'avais déjà
essayé de reprendre contact avec son
papa par l'intermédiaire de sa maman
et mais j'avais aucune nouvelle et en
fait je l'ai joué au bluff un jour
j'étais en poste et j'ai fait bonjour
c'est le commissariat de Montpellier
s'il vous plaît vous demandez à Monsieur
Untel de me rappeler et il l'a fait et
il l'a fait et donc de là à un moment où
Yasmine a a a exprimé ce besoinlà qui
était viscéral hein que je ne pouvais
que comprendre pour l'avoir vécu et ben
elle a pu rentrer en contact avec lui à
avoir un lien et aujourd'hui ils ont
toujours un lien tous les deux et et je
voulais vraiment pas qu'elle vive cette
cette douleur interne viscérale parce
que c'est ça peut être une douleur très
profonde hein c'est que tu connaissais
que je connaissais c'est pas possible
ouais non je j'aurais pas pu j'aurais
pas pu
d'ailleurs je ne veux vraiment pas qu'il
passe par le tiers des des difficultés
que j'ai pu avoir c'est c'est pas
concevable en fait pour moi je veux pas
qu'ils ai mal en fait tu n'as cessé
d'être tourmenté par l'absence de ton
père en fait ça a été miraculeux mire ça
a été miraculeux parce que après
l'émission j'ai eu un coup de fil à
l'abri et euh ce monsieur se présentait
avec mon papa non si et euh et moi qui
pensais vraiment qu'il m'avait renié
hein parce qu'il savait que j'avais été
maman célibataire que tu n'avais plus de
nouvelles que j'avais plus de nouvelles
et en fait non il savait pas il savait
pas on m'avait menti encore une fois
hein parce que toutes les années de
Verance où je cherchais mon
papa j'ai appris qu'en fait il y avait
une personne dans mon entourage proche
qui avait des liens avec lui donc moi je
fugais je le cherchais mais elle elle
avait un contact téléphonique avec et
ouais
ouais et et tout ça et ben voilà et il
t'a retrouvé après l'émission il t'a
appelé après l'émission oui il m'a
appelé on a pu parler on a parlé très
très longtemps très très longtemps et
euh malheureusement on se dit toujours
qu'on a le temps de se revoir et la vie
fait que Ben après c'est trop tard il
est décédé en
96 suite à un accident et j'ai pas eu le
temps de le voir par contre il a eu le
temps de voir Yasmine ah c'est beau et
ça c'est beau et c'est trist et ça c'est
super important c'est c'est essentiel
dans dans ton histoire essentiel dans ma
reconstruction personnelle ça a été
essentiel sais c'est une chose que
j'apprends là qui tavais appelé après
l'émission tu t'es dit quel temps perdu
quel
gâie même pas même pas en fait j'avais
encore cette petite part d'inconscience
qui faisait qu'on viit à l'instant
présent et et qu'on pense ni à hier ni à
demain ni à mais ça a suffit en tout
casi ah oui déjà avec lui oui ça m'a
suffi largement comme
je pense qu'il me il m'aurait fallu que
ça en fait il m'aurait fallu que ça même
un coup de téléphone un enchange un
échange téléphonique cette possibilité
là
pour pour éviter de vivre certaines
choses et encore j'en suis peut-être pas
si sûr de vivre quoi pour éviter quoi ce
manque ce manque intérieur ce manque
intérieur ce malette ce besoin de de te
mettre en danger hein parce que c'est ça
j'étais toute jeune he je partais à
l'aveuglette je me retrouvais dans les
rues de Paris ça pouvait être la rue de
Pigal ça ça pouvait être n'importe où
oui j'avais besoin de savoir où il était
quoi j'avais besoin de lui parler
j'avais besoin de le voir j'avais besoin
de j'ai que très très peu de souvenirs
très très peu de souvenirs et j'ai le
souvenir que je sauté sur le lit de mes
parents le jour où il est venu me dire
au revoir quand même ça c'est resté
ancré je le revois avec cette vieille
trousse de toilette qu'ils avaient à
l'époque dans les années 80
ouais je le vois me dire on se revoit
bientôt là il faut que je parte
qu'est-ce que vous recherchez vous
auprès des hommes et des garçons en fait
au début je je cherchais je cherche je
pense encore le réconfort que mon père
n'a pas pu me donner la tendresse quoi
qu'il a pas pu me donner qu'il a donné à
mes frères et sœurs en 1994 tu disais
que tu attendais le réconfort des hommes
aujourd'hui tu dirais quoi ah non non
non non j'en suis plus du tout là en
fait je suis plus du tout au stade où où
j'attends un homme pour me sauver en
général je préfère qu'ils se sauvent
d'abord
eux-même pour je préfère pourquoi c'est
ce qu'ils te disent ah ben tu as
toujours le beau chevalier avec son
cheval blanc qui arrive qui a une vie
parfaite et qui veut t'emmener là-dedans
et en fait tu te rends compte que c'est
à toi de le sauver quoi AR le bateau il
part à la dérive non non non j'en suis
plus là du tout j'en suis plus là et en
général j'attends quand même d'un homme
avant qu'il investisse ma vie il
commence déjà par régler la sienne et
après éventuellement on pourra faire un
chemin ensemble je crois que le
catalogue des hommes toxiques je l'ai
tout fait je l'ai fait je l'ai fait je
l'ai fait j'ai feuilleté c'est comme la
c'estàdire alors j'ai j'ai eu des tas
d'expériences j'ai eu des expériences de
vie hein comme comme toute femme qui
s'assume he et normalement constitué et
euh non aujourd'hui aujourd'hui non pour
l'instant je suis célibataire je dis
bien pour l'instant parce que ce que
j'attends de l'amour est bien différent
de ce que j'en
attendais il y a quelques années encore
hier et moi tout ce que je veux
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai binom quoi
j'ai pas du tout envie d'être avec
quelqu'un qui
euh qui est célibataire mais marié qui
est célibataire mais veuf à la fois
enfin qui est veuf mais qui est pas veuf
en fait parce que la femme l'attend à la
maison j'ai j'ai pas envie de ça quoi
dans ma vie j'ai j'ai pas envie de ça
j'ai envie d'autres choses j'ai envie
d'être dans le partage j'ai envie de
progresser avec l'autre j'ai envie
d'avoir
des des projets des projets mais tu n'as
pas rencontré un seul homme avec lequel
tu te sentes bien si je si si si si je
me suis marié avec et puis pu ah oui oui
quand même oui mais j'ai tout fait oui
alors dis-moi tu t'es marié quand même
je me suis mariée en 2014 ok ça a fini
par un divorce mais ouais on peut dire
ouais que mon ex-mi a été un homme qui
m'a apporté et qui m'a appris que les
hommes ne fonctionner peut-être pas tous
de la même façon bah c'est sûr ah oui
c'est sûr mais ça il fallait en être
[Rires]
convaincu tu es toujours aussi déterminé
parce que tu étais comme ça hein très
déterminé ouais je m'en rends pas compte
en fait V fragile et en même temps très
déterminé ça c'est ça toute façon tu le
voulais ce bébé tu avais mais
att ça pouvait pas être Yasmine c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a fait que à
l'intérieur de moi et dans toute ma
trajectoire ça ne pouvait pas être
autrement
ouais c'était la première pierre de de
reconstruction c'était un appel au
secours et en même temps elle venait
tellement là te donner de l'amour tout
ce que tu voulais ou oui puis elle m'a
tellement remis en place aussi des fois
hein c'est le privilège d'être parents
parce que ça ne doit pas être évident
évidemment non ça pas ça pas été simple
en fait à l'arrivée de son frère comme
par hasard elle avait 14 ans justement
tu as dû avoir peur pour elle non tu tu
t'es posé des questions quand elle avait
ton âge ouais mais elle fonctionnait
différemment c'est c'est vraiment un
sentiment profond et puis et puis le
fait qu'elle soit en relation avec son
père en fait je pense que j'avais à
quelque part balayé la possibilité que
ça puisse se reproduire je me suis pas
trop mal débrouillé quand même j'étais
petite mais c'est pas trop mal très bien
très très bien ce soir on vous met ce
soir on vous met
le est-ce que tu te souviens pourquoi tu
as fait fait cette émission Bell masque
à l'époque je pense que pour moi ce qui
était important et ce qui l' aujourd'hui
parce que quand j'ai revu que ça avait
réapparu je me suis dit ça doit pas être
anodin j'espère que ça servira à une
jeune ou à quelqu'un qui en a vraiment
besoin je crois qu'il est important de
dire que les secrets de famille les ns
dit les ça peut ça emmène des gens à des
situations extrêmes et terribles en fait
et je suis pas un cas isolé non hein et
il y a bien des cas encore bien plus
grave
et j'espère juste que ça va permettre un
jour aux parents ben juste d'oser parler
en fait juste oser
communiquer communiquer avec vos enfants
quoi ne les c'est pas dans cette douleur
interne qui ne se referme pas
facilement sacrée blessure ouais qui
amène à se mettre en danger ou à
s'autodétruireuire ou à s'autodétruire
ou et toi tu as trouvé le palliatif
c'est ça mais je me serais peut-être
autodétruite aussi je ne sais pas
c'est je pense qu'à un moment donné il y
a il y a plusieurs chemins
et et selon lequel on prend et ben on
revient pas quoi
aujourd'hui c'est le message que tu veux
faire passer en étant là c'est ça
surtout parler à vos enfants quoi ne les
laissez
pas dans le silence des nonit ne le
laissz pas comme
ça pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne in
mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche